très philippe crevel économiste
spécialiste des questions
macroéconomiques analyse les annonces
faites par le chef de l'état le secteur
de huit français est en crise depuis
trois années
c'était lié à des problèmes structurels
qui concerne pas simplement l'industrie
automobile française avec la transition
énergétique avec la diminution donc les
moteurs diesel avec le développement
hâtivement modèles encore mais qui a
vocation à prendre de l'importance de
l'électrique ni de changement de
comportement de la part des
consommateurs qui conserve plus en temps
leur voiture qui en achètent moins et
donc de ce fait l'industrie automobile
et était déjà avant la crise sanitaire
en situation de difficulté avec deux
grands groupes français et ça et renault
qui avait connu des difficultés là en
2014 avec une intervention de l'état
avec une participation chinoise et
l'autre renault qui était confronté
depuis donc le départ de carlos ghosn à
un vrai séisme internes qui pourraient y
avait du mal à se remettre
donc on va dire que la situation va dire
de l'industrie française était
compliquée avant même la crise le plan
ii des manuels macron pour sauver
l'automobile française de 8 milliards
d'euros
on va dire que c'est un effort
conséquent un preneur pour un secteur
qui est majeure en france c'est plus de
400000 emplois directs voire 900 mille
quand on prend tout en compte tous les
services associés à l'automobile 8
milliards d'euros
certes si on compare par rapport aux à
air france bazire ce n'est pas énorme
mais par rapport à la situation du
secteur automobile c'est quand même un
geste relativement fort pour de la part
du gouvernement et du chef de l'état
c'est un peu du protectionnisme sans
dire on est dans une époque très
particulière on peut faire du
protectionnisme sous couvert en fait de
sauver les entreprises d'une faillite
générées par la crise sanitaire les
sites en question était licite en
difficulté avant crise